let's go next to noble from salt lake
city utah noble you were on the air
hello david a long time viewer how are
you i'm doing well
that's good
my question is more so why aren't people
on the left and the right like doing
overtures of all the branches and
working more so towards
economic
and um
and political change for the better than
the than they are right now
what's their incentive to do that
their their incentive to do that against
that right now is mostly um culture war
issues but the incentive to do that
right now is more or less like um
living um
basically living standards being him
being met at least like health care
um or
or even scansellation of student debt or
hell even holding some
people him people who are in power for
um accountable for fraud or
or whatever not okay so here's the
problem you're thinking about this as if
as if elected officials care primarily
about
i'm not asking uh people on in congress
no i'm asking ordinary people
oh uh i so so tell me exactly what the
vision is then so i mean the product the
issue i get i think the problem is noble
that
there's a whole bunch of people who
don't agree about those issues so like
to get left and right working together
on health care you would have to get
some of those people agreeing on what
the solution is and they mostly don't to
get left and right working on student
loan forgiveness you would have to get
people on left and right in agreement on
on forgiving student loans we we just
don't have that right now there's
actually unfortunately very little
overlap on many of those issues there
there is one issue that i keep seeing
overlap almost entirely between the left
and the right and that is corruption
itself
uh you know you're not wrong but the way
in which they want to tackle the see
here's the problem on the corruption
right now
the right has no interest in holding the
trump administration accountable for its
rampant corruption and there's really no
way for the right to join the left
against corruption right now
without it going squarely against so
many members of the trump administration
that's a disincentive for the right to
act on the corruption issue right now
for now yes but for the rest of congress
most the right hates congress yes
the house and the senate and that's it
more so democrats and republicans and
admittedly mostly republicans who don't
follow trump certainly certainly listen
i wish that what you're suggesting was
more plausible it feels implausible
right now i hope that changes
yeah now here's my second question
i see a golden opportunity for people to
run for congress because right now it
doesn't take a lot of effort just to
beat uh republicans and democrats and
if people if ordinary people were to run
against these people
why um how do you how do you think um
how well do you think p ordinary people
would do against incumbents like
like blue dog republican and democrats
and republicans in all congress so
i want to see i want to see it i'm with
you that i want to see it statistically
the candidate who raises more money wins
and it is tough for random everyday
people to raise anywhere near the money
that an incumbent would raise but i do
want to absolutely see more of it noble
from salt lake city thank you so much
for the call we're going to take a quick
break and then we will be back with more
of your calls so if you're standing by
to talk to me don't hang up we'll be
right back to it in a moment
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 percent off monk
packs keto nut and seed bars which taste
just like your favorite sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10
if you don't love monk pack as much as i
do they will refund you all your money i
think there's a really good chance monk
pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout